yeah any problem i face when i'm solving
are we still on the ocean bars i'm
intelligent dolphin hmac i'm off the top
i'm killing all in anguish yeah and
we're the dolphins cause i speak a deep
language yeah i'm all up in it and i'm
spitting the ill they like mag how do
you breathe yo i got me some gills i
been going deep man can't nobody diss me
said i'm breathing through the gills but
my flow is never fishy
yeah hey yo i make these rappers flee
the scene hey yo off with their heads
like a guillotine hmac man it is quite
confusing we're the guillotines in five
four three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of the genius
brain podcast i am your host david so we
also have edric park in the house also
known as ed2 and a very very special
special guest [ __ ] hairy man
hey let's go okay before we even start
before we even start though i gotta say
this is my opinion yeah as as a longtime
hip-hop fan somebody who's done hip-hop
i gotta say bro like
you are one of the best if not the best
freestylers not only of right now but of
all time damn in my opinion in my
opinion cause like thank you it's facts
to me you know i don't even say it's an
opinion actually i take that back it's
fast
it's blushing
man i mean it's crazy so if you guys
don't know who harry mack is okay so i i
actually started seeing you on youtube
uh years ago yeah right and you were
kind of like just doing this random
freestyle [ __ ] on a beach right i was
like yo who the [ __ ] is this guy right
and so
like i hadn't heard of your name in a
bit right because i was doing my own
thing and then lo and behold i saw you
[ __ ] rap in front of kendrick that's
right yeah right yeah and i was like
okay this guy looks so [ __ ] familiar
and it was from those videos that i saw
when you were doing it at the beach
right venice beach right venice beach
right and you just come up and freeze
down with a lot of people and a lot of
people don't know like well they
probably do know but this the the art of
freestyling is so different now right
right right and right people talk about
freestyles a lot of them they're they
aren't freestyles right it's written
right which is not a problem right like
we had well recently on la leakers j
cole came out and he kind of spit his
bars right like oh dope is freestyle
that was heat but it was
written 10 years 10 15 years ago yeah
nobody would have ever said that was a
freestyle right like it wasn't off the
top it was written not to say it wasn't
[ __ ] dope i flipped out over that
[ __ ] it was hell yeah me too it was
incredible yeah crazy right yeah and
then we see somebody like you who's
a freestyler like legit
right you know it's it's not written and
so i i think that's the thing too like
important distinction there of what
freestyle is right so like
like what you're alluding to classically
like historically freestyle was really
something that you did off the top yeah
and it started to kind of evolve into
like well even if you have writtens if
you're kind of like conjuring it up on
the spot it's technically a freestyle
yeah right yeah it's totally like an
issue of terminology exactly right like
i think and it's funny too because
actually
there are quotes from like i think like
big daddy kane and people from like that
era like the 80s era like early hip-hop
where they're saying like a freestyle is
basically just a written verse about
nothing in particular
even back then okay so it wasn't
necessarily improvised but it was just a
verse without like a subject to it it
was just like a lyrical flex and then
you know at some point i don't know when
in the history it came to mean off top
improvised rhyme like we're talking
about right what i do yeah and then now
it's almost like it came full circle
back to what they were saying back in
the 80s where it's like a freestyle most
of the time like 99 of the time if the
video says freestyle um if it's funk
flex or sway or whatever it's not off
the top no it's just a written verse
that's not necessarily about one thing
usually it's an extended verse often
it's not really on an album or anything
like that it's like the only place
you're hearing it is there on the radio
yeah and it's just like a lyrical flex
so for you did you grow up in los
angeles i grew up in portland oregon
okay man this is this story's getting
interesting
so you're a white student from portland
oregon yeah that's probably arguably one
of the best freestyle rappers that has
ever [ __ ] time all the time
and this is not an exaggeration if you
guys haven't heard them intermittently
between the podcast you know turn it off
go listen to it and then come back to
this conversation because you'll you'll
see what we're talking about yeah you
know so how did you get into like
freestyling just rapping in jail like
hip-hop culture in general man so i mean
i fell in love with hip-hop when i was a
little kid you know probably second or
third grade and really what happened was
my older sister she's three years older
than me she came home from school one
day i remember and she was like yo all
the cool kids are listening to either
z100 which was the pop station or 95.5
jamming 95.5 which was the mainstream
rap station in portland and you know
obviously as a little second or third
grader i was like well i want to be cool
you know so i checked out the stations
and for whatever reason i was more drawn
to uh jamming 95.5 i was drawn to the
rap station
and um i guess that was just because of
like the sonic quality of the music you
know i think it really was it was like
the low end and the bass and like the
smacking drums yeah
like my body was rocked by it you know
yeah i became addicted to the feeling
you know i was like i want to i want to
feel that again that was like the
coolest [ __ ] i ever felt who was on at
the time like who was who was in
rotation yeah that's a great question
man so this would have been like late
like very late 90s into 2000 2000 or
early 2000s so like yeah growing up i
mean it was a lot of like you know it
was like ja rule and ashanti i was like
yeah very popular kind of like
mainstream stuff right like
yeah but then there were but then
legends as well you know it was eminem
it was dre this huge snoop was huge jay
and nas were still super active and
really popular on on radio as well so it
was a mix you know buster rhymes right
right break your neck was the jam and so
yeah in the beginning it was just
mainstream hip-hop like that and then a
couple years later like when we got into
middle school sixth grade or whatever um
that's when the freestyle thing started
to started to pick up for me we would go
hang at my friend brady's house every
day after school he had cable i didn't
have cable at home
so we would go to the cool kid with the
cable yeah like he had all the channels
we had like five channels and they
intended that you had to like adjust
um so we would go kick it with brady and
stuff
his house was on the walk home from
school so we'd post up there and we
would watch like you know bet vh1 mtv
whatever anywhere where they were
showing music related stuff yeah and so
we were checking out like
106 in part freestyle friday
when jin had his run there too yeah
right then exactly jin was like the god
and we were watching him and studying
him and and we were watching like rap
city the basement right now right
yeah and
when we realized that it was like oh
they're improvising this like in the
moment you know like
it it's so
magical to to see that where it's like
you know
i guess it's like if you go to a big
rock show there's like sets and
pyrotechnics and like the drummers on a
platform that floats over the crowd and
stuff like that right yeah and like what
these guys are doing is like none of
that it's like just showing up with
their brain
and their mouth like these these tools
that we all have and wake up with daily
that's all it is and using their
imagination they're like blowing
people's brains wide open you know and
just it was it was addictive i think the
the crazy thing is though right like
everybody got influenced in that
specific era what the whole world was
coming out you know and everyone's like
oh i want to be a rapper now you know i
got i want a freestyle battle right i
know one of the most embarrassing
moments of my life is because of [ __ ]
like that you think like you could rap
i'm like oh he did i could do it and
then you go out somebody just murders
you yeah and then you never come out of
your room for a [ __ ] month exactly
you know oh dude yeah that's but that's
kind of like your rite of passage though
right like you gotta go through that you
gotta embarrass yourself you gotta get
humbled and recognize oh [ __ ] i'm not
that dude i i got work to do if i really
want to do this and also that that's
what will set you apart in terms of like
okay i went through this adversity do i
still want to do it that's how you know
you love it you know yeah yeah i got
destroyed in a rap battle man when i was
in seventh grade i got beat by the sixth
grader too
at the time
yeah like we became friends after he's
actually still rapping he's really dope
his name is milk shout out to milk uh
he's he's in portland but yeah he
crushed me man he was a great younger
and i showed up to the lunchroom and
like he brought all his homies and he
had his crew ready to be like oh after
every line and it was just me and brady
and yeah you know
he's like come on brady hit me up bro
yeah you know that was a lot to ask of
man
so how do you like start from okay
because like i said when we're talking
about freestyling right like you you had
examples before you that you're you you
kind of started wrapping yourself right
but your style's so very unique here's
the thing that's unique about the way
that you freestyle that a lot of people
if you don't know music it's very odd
yeah your tempo
switches all the time and also like your
rap style flips up which is very very
difficult that's the most impressive
thing is that your your rhyme scheme
changes
right to like in the moment right which
is not easy to do no you know what i
mean like that really like you ride the
beat
so well when you're freestyling like
you're in the pocket i'm like how the
[ __ ] is this guy doing this man i mean
honestly like that all comes down to the
fact that i'm a drummer oh yeah
so you got that rhythm flowing through
your veins yeah yeah i'm a jazz drummer
that's what i went to college for i've
been playing drums for as long as i've
been rapping makes sense yeah i started
playing the drums when i was 10 which is
like right around the same time i
started writing my first rhymes and then
freestyling soon after so that's what
brought me down to la actually i went to
music school at usc for the jazz studies
program as a drummer that's [ __ ] nuts
yeah so all of that like though and i
gigged for years as a drummer through
los angeles playing you know bars and
restaurants and and venues and shows so
um
that's like a huge cheat code man the
whole rhythmic part of it right right uh
being able to improvise rhythmically
that's the job of a jazz drummer you
know so that part is very much
internalized and so to me like a
freestyle rap is very much like a jazz
drum solo with words right right how
[ __ ] crazy is that
because that that helps fill in that gap
a little bit right
because it's so unique like nobody does
that
and you know also too when we talk about
freestyling too you know if it was off
the top sometimes people couldn't do it
on beat like you get a freestyle rapper
that's doing this thing like battle
rapping right you put a beat in the mix
they can't rap there's a bpm that they
thrive in you know and then once it gets
like out of that whether it's slower or
faster it might kind of take them out of
their comfort zone totally right but for
you it's just like fluid you cover the
whole spectrum and i'm just like okay
this guy can speed it up that will he
could slow it down at will and still
maintain like the rhyme scheme and still
be on beat like that's nuts man
appreciate it yeah i mean that's always
been important to me the whole time i
was working on freestyling and and still
to this day when i'm practicing and
developing it's like
i want the musicality to be there
because i want it to be a thing where
when you listen to it i never wanted it
to be like oh it's pretty dope for a
freestyle right you know what i mean
it's pretty dope because he's making it
up right now right i wanted it to feel
like nah man it's just dope like it just
sounds good like it already sounds like
the finished product it sounds like
maybe you would have written it that way
and performed it that way and i think
like you say that's the big piece that's
that's missing for a lot of mcs who
occasionally freestyle right and haven't
really developed that skill set is it
it'll be dope and maybe it'll have some
bars in it and some cool wordplay and
things like that yeah but the pocket is
missing and that's kind of forgiving
because it's like it doesn't need to
have the pocket right it's a freestyle
right my thing was like man why can't
the freestyle also have you know that
that same rhythmic
pocket and fluidity and and and all the
different styles and switches of the
flow and double time and triplets
because it's too [ __ ] hard that's why
people have been wanting to
i'm sure people have thought like i i
want to do that
but yeah well you know but i do have to
say like shout out to like the og
freestylers you know supernatural juice
oh super mad man you know yeah yeah
juice freestyle fellowship for sure
because those cats are very much in the
pocket when they're doing their
freestyles as well and they're actually
the the ones that showed me that that
was even possible that's great you know
when i was young like i wouldn't have
thought that that was possible yeah the
first time i heard supernatural i was
like that's impossible yeah that was
just my i was like there's no there's no
[ __ ] way yeah um so who are your like
uh hip-hop influences growing up then
let's like
in a more personal circle right so like
instead of just like you know artists
and stuff who was like in your group in
your circle that kind of helped you out
yeah man so definitely brady who i
mentioned you know that's whose house we
would go over to and hang out at um
him and i are still close friends and
and uh he was into like turntablism and
scratching and stuff like that okay like
when we were in middle school we had
this thing where like i had started
writing my rhymes and he had one of
those fabric binders and the fact if you
remember with the zipper yeah
that's hilarious dude trapper keepers
was it was that was something yeah
exactly yeah yeah it's the equivalent of
having a rolly bag
exactly so funny like i wouldn't even
remember that those exist except for
this story which is that it had like the
fabric had a rough texture to it and so
he would like use his pencil and get
like this because he would rub the tip
of his pencil against the rough fabric
of the binder to create like a like a
scratching sound yeah
with the pencil yeah and i would do my
rhymes and stuff all he was doing is
scratching on the binder and then uh we
ended up learning about there was a like
a pamphlet that got handed out in school
for music lessons at this place called
ethos which was like a non-profit for
music lessons and they happen to have
lessons in turntablism like to learn how
to scratch and be a hip-hop dj and mix
and stuff like that and so
um brady ended up like begging his
parents uh for like you know a beginner
set of turntables and getting signed up
for those classes and the teacher there
was a big influence on us and a huge
help when we were young um
his name was dj apostle and he was just
like a dope um hip-hop you know uh dj in
portland and so he started teaching
brady and then eventually brady was like
oh like my boy harry is a rapper and i
started coming through and hanging out
and he was like a real mentor to us man
he was probably like in his 20s or
something we were 12 years old and i
think he just thought it was bugged out
that these two like 12 year old kids in
portland were like deep into learning
how to rap and stuff i'm sure it
inspired him too you know made him fall
in love with hip-hop again to see like
that excitement because like dude that
that excitement in youth when they're
passionate about something discovered
for the first time it's infectious man
hell yeah yeah you know it's also too
it's like i've al from when i've watched
your first videos till now right yeah
you definitely practice a lot because
you even gotten better since i've seen
you before you used to have your filler
where was your was your name yeah it's
gone now
it's not all the way gone
it's pretty much not [ __ ] existing
that's the first thing i noticed his
filler word's gone yeah i was like how
the [ __ ] are you doing
was that really hard for you to get rid
of
before we continue this podcast my brain
farts we are brought to you by purple
and i can't tell you how much i love my
purple mattress because it has been
giving me some of the best sleeps of my
life start loving yourself by respecting
your rest with a purple mattress shame
on you if you are hurting your own back
what that back do to you bless yourself
with the purple mattress my friends
purple technology in their products
keeps me cool supports my back sides
hips necks and shoulders gives me better
support than your husband or wife has
ever given you that's a lot better than
anything you've had so guess what too
free shipping and return so there's
really nothing that you should be
waiting for to get the best sleep of
your life purple is comfort reinvented
right now you'll get 10 off any order of
200 or more go to purple.com brain 10
and use promo code brain10 that's
purple.com brainted promo cone brain 10
for 10 off any order of 200 or more
purple.com brainted promo code brain10
terms apply
yeah yeah yeah so uh i'm obsessed with
practicing you know i've been obsessed
with practicing since since the drums my
first instrument was the violin my dad
had to make me practice like i was like
seven i would cry and stuff like that
whatever uh and my dad made me practice
which shout out to my dad because it
instilled that uh i learned that through
practice you can get better when i got
the drums i was like all i want to do is
play and so that same thing applies to
my freestyling i practice all the time
and getting rid of the filler phrase to
answer your question yeah man it's super
difficult um
pretty much every freestyler has their
identifiable filler phrases and you
can't say the n words
um but yeah man like i created exercises
that uh you know allowed me to work on
reducing that you know so i really like
made it a focal point yeah it's funny
too though because freestyling is a live
art right so it's like
normally you're not recording it and
watching it back you're just like in a
cipher with homies yeah so for years and
years and years like i have my filler
phrases but no one ever really called me
out on it or recognized it as an issue
because it was just so live in the
moment you almost don't even hear it
yeah but as soon as we started filming
it and putting the videos out you
started seeing the comment section was
like you say harry mack every bar i was
like no i don't and then i started
listening to it and i was like oh my god
i say harry mack everybody and it was
like okay like this is a real thing and
so once we started recording it man it
changed the game and and i i was really
able to see patterns and see like the
areas and the weaknesses that i could
work on to get better where did you come
up with the idea just to go out in
public and start recording this stuff
because that has to be like a moment
where you're like i'm dope at this [ __ ]
and people need to see this
yeah you know what man like for years
and years i was freestyling and you know
my friends and and family members and
people who were close to me knew that i
was crazy with the freestyles but i was
just afraid to kind of put it out there
like that and you never know you know
friends and family kind of gas you up
sometimes exactly like i'd be drawing
something on a napkin they're like
you're like picasso bro exactly
exactly you can trust that feedback and
you know yeah for sure man and i was
just dealing with my own insecurities
and like you know i wasn't ready to put
it out there like that what ended up
happening was a a friend of mine jacob
man he's like a great jazz uh piano
player and composer he was coming out
with a jazz record and he wanted to
promote it so he hit me up and was like
hey man can you you know i made this
song can you freestyle over it while we
drive down sunset boulevard i'll film it
on my phone and i just want to throw it
up and promote my record
and i was like yeah man it was like a
favor to a friend you know showed up
filmed that we drove down sunset i
freestyled about everything i could see
it took like 20 minutes we got lunch i
forgot about it week later i woke up
from a nap and my roommate at the time
was like hell bro you're going viral
right now and i was like what are you
talking about and she was like yeah your
video this video of you rapping is like
number one on reddit videos and that's
crazy man yeah so that was what kind of
like that was the catalyst you know
honestly like shout out to jacob man
because like he knew i was dope and uh
he kind of like pushed me uh past my
insecurities of doing it and as soon as
i saw the feedback i was like okay
no time to be scared anymore just like i
might as well see right you know i might
as well lean into this and see i'm so
passionate about it i love it i do it
all the time anyway yeah you know i'm
obsessed with it like no more being
scared even if i am scared [ __ ] that
like just make the [ __ ] and put it out
there yeah yeah cause like the obviously
there's some people that [ __ ] with it
you know so let's see oh you got you got
a lot of people [ __ ] with it yeah
yeah i'm lucky it's interesting because
like i think like
i'm pretty sure everybody including your
fans can sense that you actually really
enjoy what you're doing yeah this isn't
like a one-time gimmick this isn't
something that you're just gonna do for
now just to get some cash and then run
away this is what you're about like you
really [ __ ] love music yeah yeah you
know which is actually very refreshing
to see you know on a space where
everything is done for clout right right
but it just happens that your talent
your passion your joy happens to get you
clout that is a byproduct of what you
love which is so cool yeah 100 man i i
feel really really blessed i feel really
fortunate like
freestyling is what i love more than
anything else in the world and music
like you said you know being a musician
i've always wanted to be a musician like
from the time i was a little kid yeah i
knew like that's the coolest [ __ ] in the
world like music is it you know i used
to like bang rhythms on my high chair
table and i was like you know i was
always into it man so to be able to do
that now full time and and like to have
fans and supporters and you know to be
able to support myself financially and
and just exist in this space as a
full-time musician is like it's such
it's a dream it really is well let me
ask you this like what do you think
about this stigma that has existed like
even when we were kids right that
freestylers freestyle rappers can't
transition into studio artists and can't
write songs right right so what do you
think about that whole idea i mean i
think it's interesting you know i think
there's there's definitely some truth to
it like historically historically there
are lots of there are lots of cases of
like incredible improvisations right in
hip-hop right who just
write a song if their life depended on
yeah or they just weren't that
interested in that you know like for
them it wasn't about like crafting a hit
record and you know figuring out how to
do that it was always about the
improvisational side of it and how to
come off the top and improvise and
freestyle yeah so i think you know um
i feel really fortunate to exist in this
era of the internet right right where
like
we don't have to like in the past it was
like okay you're a dope freestyler yeah
when do we get a hit record and how can
we promote you so we can put you on tour
to perform the songs and everyone will
sing along like yeah it just doesn't add
up yeah you know yeah but now like with
youtube and stuff like that um
i don't need to like uh conform to that
sort of structure you know it's like
well people like the freestyles like i
can create video content based around me
freestyling right or even create songs
based around me freestyling and and that
can be the content so are you are you
like very conscious of that then is like
what your brand is and how you promote
and market yourself
uh yeah i think i think i am you know
yeah for me though the big thing is like
in terms of branding it's always been
like
if i can just be myself completely at
all times that's the goal because then i
don't have to think about the brand you
know yeah i don't want to have to like
strategize well that's the thing now
like especially with this like social
media platform stuff yeah you are the
brand exactly that's it you don't need
to create anything people follow you
because they enjoy what you do
so and also too in a world now it's like
i think authenticity is very hard to
find so for sure see it
they really do appreciate it right
because you see a lot of people too like
i know a lot of white boys that i grew
up with like every time they did hip hop
suddenly the way they speak would change
how they would act will change it's like
nobody told you how to do any of that
but you're authentically you but you're
also in a genre that's you know
developed by you know black culture but
you're still harry mack yeah from day
one till now yeah i think the
authenticity like comes through i mean
it cuts through like you can tell
honestly when somebody's trying to like
put up a front and and there's like that
superficial layer of like they're trying
to be something yeah but then for you it
just feels very gent like that's you
like you're breathing speaking living
harry mack that's just what you are you
know man i appreciate that and i do
think you know i think hip-hop is about
authenticity at least like you know
historically like that's kind of
what the most important value is is
being authentic you know so so in my
mind like you know like as a white
person you know if i'm gonna contribute
to hip-hop and be a part of this music
that you know like you say is created by
black people you know and and is a
reflection of black culture at least was
in in the beginning you know um and
still to this day very much is um
i feel like the best way that i can sort
of like honor that culture is to try to
be authentically myself you know and and
i think that's important yeah you know
when you when you started doing the
omegle stuff that's when i re-found all
your videos i'm like yo this is crazy i
mean the most fascinating part of that
video is watching somebody's face when
you say can i freestyle for you yeah
they're kind of like this [ __ ]
i'm trying to see some crazy
all right here we go and then you're
like give me three words right and
sometimes the funniest [ __ ] is you could
tell some of these kids are high as [ __ ]
because they go give me three words they
go okay
first word toilet paper that's too [ __ ]
you know short phrases the rules are
loose yeah i let it pass you know yeah
yeah yeah yeah
no but i think the dopest thing about
like your omegle raps were that
when
you're able to like really touch these
people through your raps and it's
visible you could see them getting
emotional and i'm like oh [ __ ] man
that's such a dope moment for you to be
able to do that for somebody through
something that you love in the moment
you have no idea who this person is you
don't know where they're at with their
life story whatever but then these
random words that they're throwing at
you turn into something that's like
actually meaningful for them and it's
like
wow man like that that's priceless in
and of itself 100 it's crazy it's crazy
because honestly when i first did the
amiga stuff it was like we were in covet
i couldn't go out in the world and do my
regular like public freestyles and
things like that couldn't rock any shows
people have been suggesting that i hop
on omegle but i didn't know if it was
just like straight up like all all dicks
you know because we used to go on as
kids
because originally it was chat roulette
yeah exactly and chat roulette was just
30 dicks in your face all the time
it was so quickly corrupted
that concept right oh random video chat
pairing yeah let's take our clothes off
you know it goes there but um but
actually uh side note they have like
these filters now where you can all
filter by topic okay so if you do that
it actually filters out most of the
dicks okay is there a dick filter like
do you want to see next specifically but
there's like an adult section okay
absolutely
but um but yeah you know when i first
started doing it man it was because of
the circumstance and i thought that it
was gonna be silly and kind of like a
gimmick and just something fun make some
quirky content and and see if people
like it you know i i didn't think it was
going to be something that would turn
into like a weekly series and i think
what really surprised me the most is
what you mentioned man the fact that it
actually like had the capacity to have
these moments where it was like i was
having a real emotional impact on other
human beings and i think like especially
with kovid you know where it was so hard
to be in a place where you were gonna
interact with strangers right like we're
no longer like going to bars and stuff
we're not like in the park for picnics
in crowded places like even at the
grocery store everybody's messed up
keeping a distance nobody's really
talking to strangers and so i think that
like there was kind of a yearning for
that type of energy you know of just
sort of blending with strangers and not
only talking to people that you know but
connecting with with people who are new
in in your world so um it was dope to
see man that it actually could create
emotional connections and be more
meaningful
beyond just being kind of like some
quirky right right i mean it starts off
as entertainment but then it becomes
like something that resonates with them
on a deep level exactly and i'm sure for
you too like you walk away from that
like oh [ __ ] dude that was that was
crazy hell yeah bro yeah i was taken
aback by him yeah some of the moments
too and like there were there were some
crazy moments where people were like
really moved by the subject matter yeah
yeah that was really cool to see yeah
like i remember a guy in particular i
think it was about like somebody he had
lost or something yeah um
and you were just like spitting bars for
him and then he was just like
getting more and more visibly emotional
and he was just super into it and i'm
like dude that's so dope that you and
like you said especially during a time
like covid right when some of these
people who like there's forced isolation
but maybe those people in their
day-to-day lives are isolated anyway
maybe they never had like the friends or
that community that they could turn to
and all of a sudden you got this random
stranger who first of all is talented
who's like doing this for you and it's
like oh my god like somebody actually
cares enough about me to even give me a
moment to like do this right that's such
a huge part of it man like that's what i
started to realize while i was doing
this content and just freestyling in
general yeah um
like people want to be seen you know i
really feel like that's such a that's
such a big part of being a human being
is like you want to feel like knowledge
you want to feel heard you want to feel
seen and the dope thing about off top
freestyling is so often it's about the
audience you know what i mean and
certainly in the omegle bars when i'm
like hey you tell me what to rap about
like you give me the three words and i'm
gonna run it through my filter and give
you something back yeah um i think that
that's that means that goes a long way
with people for sure for sure yeah so
have you ever done the omegle thing and
they just got pissed at you
started rapping around for me bro
i mean i've been skipped you know i've
been skipped a couple times yeah uh when
i'm just like feeling it
yeah i never really had anybody like get
pissed per se or yell at me um like a
couple times you know because i don't
tell them i'm recording it till
afterwards okay i think a couple times
people felt like they kind of got
tricked like they weren't down to be
they were like oh what you were
recording me you're like nah man what
the [ __ ] you know really just a couple
times people are cool all right what
let's say let me ask you this what was
like the oddest or like strangest
interaction you've had during the whole
series so fun uh there's this one it's
actually in the video
um with these puppets it was just like
it showed up and it was like this this
puppet and the the puppeteer had like a
voice altering effect on his mic or
whatever and it was just like hello you
know it was like it was the creepiest
[ __ ] you've ever seen yeah it was like
horror movie level like people were
scared of the [ __ ] video when it came
out what the hell it was crazy and it
turns out it's this like content creator
named puppet world
okay this person actually has like a
channel with like a decent number of
subscribers i think on youtube and
they're like doing their thing in the in
the puppy
yeah just doing the same thing you are
just with puppets and yeah he's doing
his act pretty much exactly yeah they
don't rap but he was trying to battle
your act he's like i'm recording you
exactly
exactly yeah there's actually a lot of
content creators on amigo it's funny if
you're on there there's a lot of
streamers i mean who would have thought
the omegle things would have been even
more popular than the original content
that you were doing hello my brain farts
once again this podcast is brought to
you by skillshare listen to me cut to
the chase you are like me you got
hobbies you have goals and a bunch of
things you want to learn and try but you
don't know where to get the right
information i hate this feeling you can
search online for hours for the right
class but i'm telling you you don't need
to deal with that [ __ ] please just
get skillshare it's an online learning
community that offers membership with a
whole bunch of meaning with so much to
explore real projects to create and the
support of other fellow creatives just
like you because skillshare is about
real community and real growth the
course i'm checking out right now is
youtube success script shoot and edit by
marcus brownlee you guys already know
i'm a huge fan of his and i love the way
that he sets up his videos and it really
helps me create my own in the organized
way and fashion that i want to create
mkbhd is the [ __ ] so remember explore
your creativity at skillshare.com brain
and get a free trial of premium
membership that's skillshare.combrain
i know like i think it is that it's that
i'm always doing it for the reaction
right it's like i can't wait to see
where the person like is in doubt i was
like look at the hate and ass face on
this [ __ ]
and then they're just like okay whatever
i'm gonna just turn you i'm like smiling
but they don't want to smile
that's the thing that makes me die it's
like just smile do you like it
they're all trying to like cover their
mouth
this is always towards the end when it
stops with the words and he's literally
describing everything that's in the room
and they're right you know this was
doing it all the time
did you see that changing their life
yeah right like oh [ __ ] that's always
the crowd pleaser it's kind of funny
because like that's the [ __ ] i've been
doing for the longest time like i've
been doing that for years like at this
point that whole like call out your
shirt color or you know the neon sign
whatever like that feels easy yeah um
but that's still always the crowd
pleaser that's like everyone's favorite
moment you know it took me so long to
figure out how to like take one word and
like expand it into like a universe and
a scheme of references and tie all that
together and that part everyone's like
all right we'll see yeah
[Music]
um you're mount rushmore of like
all-time greatest who is it i've been
curious about it
bro yeah so that's four right yeah
it's usually the top five but then
mountain rush more it's four you know
rush four is four all right so
man like four my four favorite artists
i mean my favorite rapper is nas okay
okay um
after that
i'm gonna go
black thought black thought okay
dude black thought is highly underrated
bro yeah yeah so highly underrated it
has been forever yeah it's dope now
because he's really getting his shine in
a major way
jimmy fallon the the yeah the fallon
show but then there was the funk flex
freestyle he did like 10 or 11
yeah well it's like within the last
few years
okay um but it went crazy viral i mean
it's like the freestyle hurt around the
world it's got like 20 million views or
something like that and it's one of the
like greatest um singular rap
performances potentially ever it's like
if you had to just like you know if if
you know when they shot that like golden
record into space that was supposed to
like encapsulate humanity or whatever in
case like an alien ever found it was
like oh okay this is what humans are
about yeah i would say if we wanted to
represent rapping just like the
technique and the skill of wrapping and
why it's impressive yeah um we just send
that on so yeah shout out to black
thought he's been a huge influence but
it's funny because i've been a huge fan
of of the roots and black thought yeah
ever but i was always like why don't
more cats like mention black thought you
know
every rapper mentions black thought but
i just feel like on that main stream
he's the rapper's rapper he's your
rapper's rap he's a rapper's rapper
straight up um all right so we got nas
we got black thought
um
man greatest greatest artists it is hard
it is hard i mean i want to say like
you know
uh i've been very influenced by snoop
i'm gonna say snoop dogg okay oh [ __ ]
having so much style yeah and being so
different yeah yeah yeah like when you
talk about being authentic i feel like
snoop dogg is so authentic to himself
and always has been
nas yeah thought uh snoop dogg and then
i'm gonna say
oh man it's so hard
he's like who's gonna take this forward
i mean i'm gonna say mf doom mf2 wow
wow that's mf doom is not usually on
like a top five list for most people
yeah
yeah yeah
in this case top four top four i know
you know it's so tough man to do the
list because i'm a fan of so many people
yeah and also
there are just so many different like
facets of hip-hop and so many different
things that
make somebody great right you know right
that's why the lists are always like
who's the top five greatest rappers of
all time it's like there is no greatest
rapper of all time right first of all
it's subjective but second of all it's
like
well what are we going to talk about are
we do we want to talk about longevity
then it has to be like the jay-z's and
the black robots right you know are we
going to talk about just sheer wrapping
technical ability then it's going to be
like the eminem's and the and and you
know um whoever else you put in that
group
sales
sold out
storytelling right you know then it's
going to be the ghost faces and the
slick ricks and cats like that and like
you know uh originality um then it's the
snoops and the and whoever else so uh
it's so hard for me to say i know it's
so everywhere but to be fair with mf
doom i mean i i'm not saying it's an
illegitimate choice i'm saying it's like
rare that you kind of hear that but
that dude once he became mf doom he took
on that character right that's something
where you like all right he's
authentically himself dude you know yeah
i was just talking about how like
everything about mf doom is like so uh
perfect for his character right and like
the enigma right right he created like
how it wasn't even him at half of his
shows yeah doom and posters who would
wear the mask
fans would get so pissed like you know
you know yeah the fans would get so
pissed like damn it wasn't even the real
deal which i understand
at least money to see this guy and it's
not him but it's like let's be honest
like culturally like we look back on
that historically like that's [ __ ]
amazing that's literally like so
original
yeah exactly like you never know if it's
really him and like he doesn't you can't
get a hold of him and he disappears for
years he was banned from the us you know
like we literally couldn't get him in
the states and like you know and even
with his passing like it was like
i think it was like he he what i can't
remember what it was but it was like we
didn't find out that he had died for
until like months after it had happened
and it was like on halloween or
something like that and everything about
it is just like as tragic as that was
like like i really like shed tears you
know when i learned that emma mf doom
the last couple years has been rough man
we just lost uh bismarck he just passed
away yep they didn't know about his
health like his health struggles and
stuff like that yeah nor did i actually
was crazy man just out of nowhere i was
like every time somebody dies i think
it's a prank because it's because it's
too frequent in this day and age in this
day and age right the first time you see
it you're like nah let me verify yeah
yeah yeah for sure i mean because there
has been many times where there are
hoaxes of like oh you know so and so
passed away right and then you're like
oh [ __ ] they passed away and then you
find that oh [ __ ] well you know he
passed away i thought it was a prank too
you're right i truly believe that yeah i
was just like no way and i just ignored
it all day and then my phone started
blowing up and then i heard this [ __ ]
up tweeted like oh rick fox died too and
they were like
that red fox had a tweet i'm not dead
why did people say
why you including me
she's chilling
just like yo rick fox rest in peace yeah
what the [ __ ] that's crazy yeah we were
out filming gorilla bars when when kobe
does
my yeah gorilla bars is like where i go
out in public rap yeah and we were out
there doing a shoot and like we we had
rap for these kids and then we moved on
we're doing some other stuff and then we
passed by them later and they're like yo
did you hear about kobe and i was like
what and they're like kobe died and i
just remember when i heard that i was
like what does that mean yeah exactly it
doesn't make sense yeah it doesn't
register for yeah like i was like that
can't be what you meant right yeah yeah
it's weird because like even people who
weren't
like i was a sacramento kings fan right
yeah so i was like he was like my
[ __ ] antichrist right
you know right but it's crazy just just
how much i didn't realize how big of a
fan i was until he passed away yeah
because he was a huge part of my love
for basketball was was the sacramento
and lakers rivalry so when he passed
away it was like a representation of a
huge chunk of my life as a kid right so
it was just that constant back and forth
and when he died i'm like oh sh i like
kobe a lot more than i thought i did
dude yeah that's nuts i mean i don't
even follow like i'm not even a sports
guy at all right now i don't even like
follow the nba but still like i was just
like there's no way it was just it was
just so uh
crazy to imagine that i mean that's
that's the true mark of greatness though
right is when you transcend what you do
exactly and people who don't necessarily
like you said even follow the sport they
know who you are though they know that
you're great at what you do oh hell yeah
i think you know like in terms of legacy
tying this to you is i feel like you're
you're going to leave that behind too
man like
i seriously don't see how anybody can
like if they're a fan of hip-hop even
like a casual fan right cannot recognize
the talent and the skill that you have
and see how hard it is to do that you
know right that's greatness people
wow
give the man his flowers while he's here
i appreciate it because before you i
think to me the
off the top when it came to a rapper
when i thought somebody who was the best
was actually a king loss oh hell yeah
you know king lost his freestyles are
[ __ ] amazing he's nice
and this is no disrespect to king lose
like still up there right but it was
just the difference thing that that
edged you was a rhyme scheme changed his
rhyme scheme never changes so which is
typical like that's how i mean most
people can't do that how the [ __ ] would
you do that yeah you know why why why
hasn't suede got you on the five fingers
to death bro cause because he doesn't
want to be there for 30 hours that's why
he's like a schedule bro
yeah no i mean hopefully eventually you
know that would be an honor that'll be
your honor yeah
i don't even know sway i'ma just spam
what is that yo sway get get it get it
right there get out
of buffs ass on there dude are you
[ __ ] kidding me well he's pretty
famous to be better yeah when shia
labeouf started freestyle rapping and
they're like yo this kid's hot i was
like he's good for shiloh buff
relax
i don't know actually he actually works
i used to work out at the gym over here
in south pass oh nice and then he got
kicked out for getting into a fight oh
really yeah
he's just he must fight people not
surprising it's not surprising he was so
loud in the gym like people don't know
he would be in the gym yeah and this is
an outdoor gym and he would somehow make
an echo because this fool would wear
super tight [ __ ] leggings ball sack
just no just outlined
i'm like so when i went to the gym i'm
like yo who the [ __ ] is this guy loud as
[ __ ] i could see his sack like what the
[ __ ] out of here stand up shia labeouf
i'm like of course oh my god
that's amazing not surprised but i guess
he beat somebody up at the gym or some
[ __ ] oh damn yeah
there are some anger issues some of
these like i always feel like these
people who are younger stars that
something happened in between that oh
yeah that that's starting yeah we've
talked about this so many times but like
there's you just not the human being is
not designed to have that type of
attention and like you know have people
cater to them when they're that young i
mean everybody essentially becomes a yes
man and a yes woman to you and it's like
your view of the world becomes so warped
that it's not grounded in reality and
then you get to the point where you're
like you're starting to discover your
identity and become an adult and you're
just [ __ ] up in all kinds of ways
because you think like the world should
be delivered to you in on a silver
platter right yeah i mean yeah honestly
like sometimes i
occasionally i would think to myself
like man if only i'd been pushing this
freestyle thing like back when i was
like younger you know because i had
people telling me like 18 19 20 21
whatever all through college like why
aren't you like doing this yeah like why
don't you like put this out bro like try
to get signed or whatever and uh
sometimes i'm like wow because i didn't
really like my first video came out when
i was 27. you know what i mean um and
that's kind of when like this whole
harry mack thing started yeah um in
terms of people knowing about me
but
in a lot of ways i'm thankful for the
way that it went down for sure because
by the time i started becoming somewhat
of like a public figure or whatever you
want to call it like by the time people
started knowing who i was yes
i was a bit older and i kind of like
knew who i was yeah exactly and i still
have a long way to go you have that
foundation there exactly yeah exactly
like i just think of like the type of
[ __ ] i was doing when i was 19 20 21
years old like i'm glad that i didn't
have eyes on me you know
i'm really glad that i was able to be
that age and like make all those
mistakes and learn from them and all
right think about being like a 14 15
year old who becomes like a content
creator right and then you got like half
of your audience just ripping you apart
all the time right how like how does
their how does that impact their psyche
and you know like there's no way that
that doesn't affect them and it's like
i'm sure it becomes trauma to them and
then they get they start to get older
and it manifests itself in a lot of
[ __ ] up way and you see that with
these child stars i would say eight nine
out of ten times
they're gonna get [ __ ] up at some
point in their life right it's more of a
surprise when they seem normal right you
know like obviously we don't know any of
them personally but then they generally
don't have controversy or they seem to
lead a normal life you're like wow i'm
surprised that person turned out that
like for example justin bieber i was
just waiting i'm like it's a ticking
time bomb this guy's been a superstar
since he was like 12 years old right
it's just a matter of time before he
hits that point where you know he's
going to get into controversy he's going
to get into trouble yeah and then it
came i think like by the time he was 18
or so right and so it's just it's it's a
[ __ ] up thing like it's a blessing and
a curse that we have this platform for
people to like launch their their
whatever their skill is or the talent is
right but it can also come with the
price because there's that anonymity
behind internet you know people just say
whatever the [ __ ] they want without
thinking about like dude this is a 14
year old kid and you're telling him he's
the worst [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] that has
ever been born into this world like come
on it's terrible i mean yeah dude i get
[ __ ] up over negative comments
sometimes you know i'm [ __ ] 31. like
i can't imagine if i was 14 like yeah
what do people say yeah what would they
say
well first i'm really lucky man yeah i
my comment section is very positive yeah
like it's kind of it's like stupidly
positive yeah like it's almost like not
that's what i would imagine that's like
you know like where are the haters like
there should be more you know um but i'm
lucky man i have a super positive
community online so it's only you know
but there's always going to be people
who say [ __ ] yeah i don't know what they
say regular stuff you're trash this is
corny yeah you know you're garbage um i
see you got some gray hair i hope you
die soon
those are definitely trolls
yeah let me just find somebody with gray
hair exactly exactly
exactly
it's all you know those those things are
funny um like that comment i'll laugh at
you know some the only comments that
kind of like affect you or affect me
anyway are like we're like yeah that
might be true you know like the harry
matt comments like you said harry mack
yeah yeah
don't you stupid [ __ ] yeah yeah exactly
oh my god
once you realize you do it's like
you hate it because it's true it's like
it's a little true it's like
exactly um so harry like what's your
thoughts on kind of the evolution of
hip-hop another thing i was curious
about what you think um from the time
that you got into it yeah to now like
what are your thoughts on that man um
you think it's it's been
um a positive
you know evolution like
like we're going in the right direction
or do you think it kind of like split
off at a fork in the road and it just
kind of kept splitting off from there no
man i think overall it's been really
positive like hip-hop is the most
popular genre in the world that's dope
you know um hip-hop is is bigger than
it's ever been and honestly like i think
right now
it's in a really dope place because
there's a there's a lot of diversity in
the game right now and and it's not all
like for a while it was like popular to
be like oh like the mainstream [ __ ] is
trash or whatever like when we were
funny enough when i was first
discovering hip-hop is when we were like
really on that tip like in middle school
we were like oh like we don't listen to
the video rap yeah we're like boujee and
we were like yo we listen to like
underground yeah
and all that and we were we were really
into underground groups blackalicious j5
you know def jux and stuff like that but
um
but uh nowadays i think there's actually
a lot of like you know um different
things going on that are winning in the
mainstream even you know you have like
of course you have like the full trapped
out auto-tune stuff yeah which you know
some of that is dope and and i [ __ ] with
a lot of that you know um but you also
have like lyrical cats like like cole
and kendrick
and then you have these like waves of
like kind of uh stuff permeating just
under the most mainstream stuff like
zelda and and like really dope like
lyrical [ __ ] that uh freddie gibbs and
artists like that who are really popping
and have big fan bases and play
festivals and [ __ ] like that yeah even
if they're not like going to radio right
there's just a lot more to choose from
now like the genre is so big because i
remember when we started hearing
i i think like the sad part for me was
when every rapper started sounding the
same right right just because they found
something that was a lot more commercial
yeah everybody's rhyme scheme was same
and i was just getting a little
exhausted with it i was like oh my god
how many [ __ ] futures can i listen to
yeah you know right but then you know
but because the music is so widespread
specifically in the hip-hop genre you
just have to look for it yeah it's it's
all there right you know it's just you
know obviously even when did you guys
watch that little quick doc with the
it was like how pop music became pop and
they were talking about the birth of
auto tune okay and like and t-pain's
influence on it and then there was a
moment where uh he was on a kind of jet
with usher was on there usher was like
yo let me talk to you for a second he
looked at us usher looked at t-pin and
said you know you really kind of killed
r b
that's that's like a dagger through the
heart you know what they did
i forgot which track they had together
but they did music together at that
point too they were good friends yeah
when he said that he said he was like
depressed for like a few months because
he had to really sit there and think did
i ruin [ __ ] r b because after that
everybody started using autotune right
right i mean there's there's no question
that t-pain popularized auto-tune it's
not that it didn't exist before him but
he put it on the map as like the thing
to do with the cool thing to do in your
music you know right the first person to
use it on a mainstream track apparently
is share yeah
yeah and so that was like uh
i forgot the creators like some some
older white dude but he's the one that
created it and they used it on shares
thing yeah and then there was a huge
debate on whether cher was doing
auto-tune or not
that's just her voice it's like no no
that's [ __ ] honest i actually
remember that debate where people were
arguing about that [ __ ] but it was
auto-tuned yo i remember that song too
because i was in the car and my mom was
driving and she was like i don't like
this song i don't like the robot voice
yeah i remember like it was like yeah
there was discussion around the robot
yeah because it was that and then before
autotune it was just a vocoder right
coders
and stuff
yeah exactly
and then you know with that input like
so apparently like t-pain was looking
for this specific thing nobody knew what
it was called yeah but there was like a
vst plug-in for it right and he just
went constantly like months searching
for it and when he finally found it he
goes this is the [ __ ]
put it out and it was just the [ __ ]
hit yeah and everybody and then kanye
west started using it in rap instead
right yeah well no he also had the 808
and heartbreak album right and that was
like heavily auto-tuned and yeah and
very depressing because that was that's
kind of that's what he was going to do
yeah that was the state he was in but
yeah definitely that period when
everything was auto-tuned i i was
getting a little bit exhausted with like
you know hip-hop music right yeah i was
like dude everybody's on this [ __ ] man
jay-z's track that's the auto-tune
yeah it wasn't the death it was not it
was definitely not because it's
definitely still mostly auto two and a
half more popular actually
i like this yeah right right and we're
still hearing it today which is crazy
yeah like if you listen to like rap
caviar playlist or mainstream you know
rap radio there's still a ton of auto
tune yeah even if it's subtle yeah it
just became a part of the sound yeah but
i think you know honestly like the most
mainstream of of the genre has always
been sort of homogenized like for sure
through all the errors like
everybody that's going to radio
for the most part they're all kind of
doing the same [ __ ] because that's the
sound that's working and that's just
getting pushed and you know but see
that's why the 90s was a special error
and they called it the golden era of
hip-hop for a reason because like then
we had west coast gangsta rap then we
had that east coast biggie you know like
and there was a distinct difference
between mainstream hip-hop you know
but then it became like everybody wanted
to do this thing well you know what even
backing up before t-pain i would blame
ja rule
and a lot of people do
yeah we're gonna if we're gonna place
blame for like what what made uh hip-hop
like become homogenized yeah like ja
rule and his melodies you know what i
mean like and 50 came on the scene and
he was beefing with you know murder ink
and jaw talking about like you know
you're [ __ ] whack because you're
singing all your [ __ ] right and then
what the 50 do right he became yeah he
became the melodic rapper singing all
the time and then that just kind of
became the thing to do and then auto
tune came and it's just like you know
yeah it's funny because like for a long
time there was there was and even still
probably today to an extent maybe
there's that whole thing of like yo it's
rap music like you know [ __ ] all the
melodic [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah you
have to sing on your on your on your
record for it to be big right definitely
in the beginning like it was like i
remember with drake it was like oh like
he's soft because he sings right you
know and like we just want to hear bars
but you know ironically i do think that
the the addition of the melody is what
is that's the reason that hip-hop is the
biggest genre globally for sure you know
yeah it's like a catchy melody is gonna
go so far yeah you know like that's
really if the whole world wants to hum
along to the melody then you know it
transcends every language it started
breaking into like when we were younger
it was about uh what was like emo rock
was like the [ __ ] because of teenage
angst well now there's emo rap and it's
hitting the same genre but now it's
bigger because it became two genres
smashed in one i mean speaking of emo
rap i don't even know because the first
person i'm thinking about is mgk right
like but i don't even say that's emo rap
people
post modernization okay yeah yeah
father of emo rap dude it's about
heartbreak crying in a [ __ ] room yeah
you're rapping yeah it was something
that people were like yo what kind of
before rap was about killing somebody
yeah it's like if i see you that's why i
[ __ ] your [ __ ] you fat [ __ ]
right and then i went to like crying in
my room right you know i was like yo
what the [ __ ] is this yeah and they like
i saw this crazy video where they took
one of those like popular emo trap songs
and they like isolated the acapella and
then they put like of like 180 sounding
yeah oh music okay rock [ __ ] over it
yeah like and it was just an emo track
like straight up yeah it was exactly the
same even the tonality of the voice like
why'd you leave me
yeah that's how the emo trap [ __ ] sounds
too it just has like 808s and you know
whatever yeah and auto-tune right but
it's it's like the most popular hip-hop
genre that i see right now just because
it's the youth you know they're all
going through all these feelings and
emotions and if that song is going to
tap into that that's what they're going
to i mean you know you know that's music
though right it's cyclical it's always
going to go in this cycle and then you
know yeah it's gonna it might take some
things that were popular before and
change it a little bit but at its core
you recognize what it is and like i
think for us we have more perspective on
that because we're a little older but
then for kids that are like you know
teenagers now they don't really have
perspective on unless they're huge music
fans they're digging like for me i
remember when i really started to get
into music
with our limited ways of discovering
music i was always digging for music you
know right especially with hip-hop stuff
like i'm like okay who's this art like
for example typical cats i'm sure a lot
of kids have no [ __ ] idea who that is
right now you know quail dennis and kane
who like first recognizable korean
rapper for me too and and quasar those
guys like
were kind of big an underground scene
back then but then today it's like who
the [ __ ] are typical cats right they're
not gonna know who that is right um
so for me yeah like digging for music
was really important and it gave me
perspective but then yeah i feel like if
you don't have that perspective then you
just think this is all brand new it's
never been touched before you know and
it's coming out for the first time
there's
so much content now you know like if you
wanted to put out an album you could
literally do it tomorrow and there's no
red tape that you go through yeah so
there's so much content and sometimes
it's harder because back in the day we
had to [ __ ] get illegal torrents that
[ __ ] on their heads
that [ __ ] sometimes when i had 56k that
was a whole day to get one song
and then if the download [ __ ] stops
at like eighty percent like oh yo the
funniest thing about live wire was like
the there were these like
super collabs like these tracks and it
would be like
tupac yeah
it was just like you know it wasn't it
was just like a people someone
this never really happened but every
time i saw it i was like yeah exactly
like is this really it is this is the
craziest collab you [ __ ] don't
know how hard it was you don't know big
cds the cdrs oh my god yeah dude my
friend elon man back in sixth grade he
was the first dude with like the cd
burner oh [ __ ] he was that dude yeah and
so like with that combination yeah you
were just the duke dude you know making
your own mix cd was like the greatest
[ __ ] feeling ever so as soon as it's
done like i can't wait to [ __ ] listen
to this you know
um kids don't know that these they don't
know
one of the early mp3 players i got it
for christmas it was such a stupid thing
like i don't know why it exists it was
like
but it was so cool at the time it was
like this little thing and and it had
like a curved edge on it it looked dope
it was black and white do you remember
what it's called ah man i can't remember
was it like the zune or some [ __ ] the
microsoft zoom that wasn't one of the
first ones buy like a microphone it was
like some random company that like you
never even would have said yeah bing bao
technology
it could fit like it was like megabytes
it could fit like
an album it was like you could have two
albums on there right 24 tracks right
and so it was like what was the point
yeah and like everyone had started
hearing about mp3s and limewire but
that's the thing though it was the
ability to like craft your own little
playlist yeah like now we could do
infinite amount of tracks on spotify or
whatever that's true but then back then
to have your custom tailored list of you
know 12 24 tracks whatever it may be
yeah that was like mind-blowing you know
yeah and nowadays it's hard to figure
out what you want to listen to man yeah
everything you're listening to i hate
that yeah like while i'm listening i'll
get like three songs into a record maybe
there's a lull it's just not speaking to
me for some reason yeah i'm like yeah
there's probably something better i
could be listening to yeah i mean after
all i have the entire world's worth of
music right here yeah maybe i'll switch
it up yeah i hate that because it used
to be man i would just have like through
high school i would have one cd in my
car cd listen to it constantly and the
way it was it would loop back to the top
when it was finished so i would just be
anywhere in the midst of this same album
for like a month yeah and it was a deep
dive and i really like would know those
albums i remember what they were it was
like james brown greatest hits that was
the only [ __ ] i listened to for a few
months um biggie ready to die yeah i
know every word on that album and always
will because of that deep dive and i
appreciate anything that was on a cd and
[ __ ] like people like you know a song
would come on and then i know half the
lyrics i'm like how do i know half the
lyrics right it's because i listened to
it repetitiously
[Music]
one of my favorite pastime activities
when i was a teenager i get high i sit
there in front of my computer turn on
some of my favorite music and watch the
[ __ ] win-app visualization something
kind of like that you know and i just be
sitting there
that's the thing though like when you're
high and and you know you like music is
different like hilarious some of my
favorite artists that i'd be listening
to when i'm when i'm high would just be
like well and then the visual element
just takes me to another level yeah and
i'm probably just zoning out there for
like two three hours just jamming the
music and watching this the same loop of
visualization
visualize it man i can see it now but
that's how you would fall in love with
albums though because you didn't have
this many resources so you were forced
to give an album a chance yeah you had
to you listen from front end to back end
because a lot of people don't know like
when when an artist who cares they make
an album there's a story from beginning
middle to end absolutely you know but
when you only listen to the beginning
part you don't see where it goes right
you're not giving the album a chance
yeah yeah but but you know to that point
i would argue too though is that like
people generally don't make albums like
they used to anymore either because it
became a singles game once the digital
stuff came into play so like people just
like well [ __ ] it i mean why do i need
to make an album they know people aren't
consuming music that's exactly that way
exactly so it's less of a priority it's
affected the way people create exactly
man and it's a little sad about that
because i used to love like
it being this concept you're starting
with this concept and executing like
everything like for example prime kanye
in my opinion like the way he executed
on concepts from like album title to the
songs the way it's structured the skits
even down to his concerts it was all
like cohesive yeah and i appreciated
that like just from a creative
standpoint but then now it's just like
well we just need to make a [ __ ] hit
song and put it on itunes it's like yeah
a lot of a lot of records are just like
back-to-back bangers she's like all
right we have this collection of songs
right hopefully a couple of them go huge
and here they all are yeah yeah
i would say today like kendrick is one
of the people that's still creating that
way that you're talking about for sure
like he's one of those guys that is just
sort of it feels like he insists on
continuing to do that yeah in spite of
what he's a purist he's a purist you
know his records are like novels you
know with that being said who do you
think like not necessarily one person
but like leaders of this generation of
hip-hop who do you think who do i think
yeah the leader i mean definitely
kendrick um
you know j cole
um joey badass joey
yeah um another dude that you freestyled
for yeah i got to meet him
for him yeah shout out to joey he's he's
always been dope um
yeah i definitely think like the whole
griselda movement is crazy with conway
the machine and benny the butcher and
those guys like they're making huge
waves like um freddie gibbs is somebody
i'm a big fan of
uh action bronson you know i think
there's a lot of dope people in this era
that are that are active and and sort of
pushing the boundaries but i guess yeah
in the mainstream like i think kendrick
is is that guy yeah yeah he's just
consistently bringing that quality yeah
well because i feel like it's not like
yeah he's a mainstream rapper but he's
not putting out like necessarily
mainstream music you know what i mean
right um and and i found that so
interesting in this era because it's
like
you know it's mainstream music tends to
have a certain sound right and here
comes this guy who's
like seemingly left field in terms of
what his sound is like right but it
still bangs and he's a lyricist and this
dude can write and tell stories right
yeah and it's like okay i wonder though
how that's going to translate to like
mainstream success though right because
it's undeniable
everybody from the west coast has passed
the torch to him from dre to like game
everyone right saying he's next up how
is that going to translate to like
mainstream success in not only the
united states but in the world now yeah
and then he did it bro he he came out
and like i was like wow man i did not
expect that level of success but i'm
happy that it is yeah and he's always
been so smart about that part like the
crossover to the mainstream yeah because
i remember man like
you know i uh one of my friends actually
was brady the same cat that i came up
with doing music was like yo check out
this dude kendrick lamar like he's he's
doing some crazy [ __ ] before like good
kid mad city and stuff like that and so
i was listening to him in college and
just like watching videos and hearing
the mixtapes and stuff that was out and
i was like yo this dude's crazy i think
he's gonna be it you know and like we
were super excited about him and then i
remember like when when good kid mad
city came out the first thing i heard
was the single uh backseat freestyle
and when i heard that i was like oh it
was a little more like mainstream
sounding than his usual [ __ ] right and i
was like okay all right like he's do
he's doing this yeah he's gonna do this
and i was like hmm i don't i didn't know
how to feel about it you know what i
mean i was like okay like is he gonna
like
sell out or whatever whatever that means
but i was kind of like oh i hope he
still remains yeah remains kendrick yeah
and then what was so genius about it was
in the narrative of the album which is
like a few days in his life when he's
like 17 years old or something like that
right
that was the moment where
uh all of his friends pulled up on him
with a bunch of weed and alcohol and
we're like yo let's freestyle yeah and
so that's like the 17 year old cocky
like kid yeah just saying like [ __ ] the
world you know i pray my dick gets big
as the eiffel tower yeah like energy and
it makes sense for it to be that song
right it makes sense for it to be that
mainstream energy so even the way he did
that was very clever you know and still
fit into his brand and like he always
finds that creative way
to to remain authentic but still like
have that mainstream opinion and and i
like completely respect when people are
able to do that because i'm sure it's
not easy man like even if you think
you're being true and pure to yourself
you got all these people surrounding you
about oh you should do this your
marketing campaign should do this you
should look like and
you kind of second guess it like yeah is
this me is this what i really want to do
or am i influenced now by these outside
factors and you know
um so i'm sure somebody in his position
it's hard to maintain like himself and
his identity and try to be pure to it
but
i feel like he's done an incredible job
with it definitely yeah definitely and
it is tough to do like for sure like
i've had my periods of time where i'm
dealing with the like oh second guessing
and wondering and feeling outside
influences and people telling me hey you
should do this you should do that yeah
you know um there was a phase where it
was like right when my videos kind of
started going viral and i was like oh
[ __ ] you know like this is an
opportunity you know and you feel all
this pressure of like you better
leverage this yeah yeah because like you
don't want to be like a viral cat video
yeah yeah you know i forgot i don't want
it to be like you had this and then you
dropped the ball yeah you know and at
that time i was like i have to figure
out how to like convert to like a
traditional
music path of a rapper you know yeah i
need to get on the radio
and it was a crazy time because like i
was like you know um i was reached out
to by like j crews and the crew show on
radio here in l.a and they brought me on
to like meet joey and put me on their
powerhouse festival which was like lil
wayne was the headliner so i was kind of
like i felt like i was like brushing
shoulders with this like stream
yeah i was like wait what oh [ __ ] like
yeah i was just freestyling at venice
beach and now i'm kind of close to this
energy yeah i need to be this you know
and you start thinking like how can i be
cooler or like how can i be a rapper you
know what i mean without realizing like
bro since you were 12 years old you've
been a rapper yeah
you you just have your own way of doing
it so like for a minute there i was mad
stressed out trying to figure out how i
was going to become like a mainstream
artist and i thought that's how i had to
leverage it nowadays i'm so much more
just on the tip of like
i do what i do you know what i mean and
and again i'm i'm lucky to live in this
time where you can build your own
audience and build your own fan base and
and and really create a community around
what you do and so that's kind of the
tip i'm on nowadays and it feels good
yeah i mean it's really smart that way
too because uh one of my buddies put it
the best way he goes you know a lot of
criticism that uh freestyle rappers get
is they go oh they can't they can't rap
on like make real music right but did
you ever ask the freestyle rapper if he
wants to right right you know right so
what is this idea that we have this
image for what somebody else should do
constantly exactly that you never ask
them like exactly did you ask the
freestyle rapper if he wants to be a
radio hit artist right what if he said
no then what is your what is your
conversation
yeah bro 100 it's like uh there was this
like mitch hedberg joke where he was
like oh mitch hedberg
he's yeah he's dope he's so dope bro
rest in peace um yeah he had this joke
where it was like every time i tell
people i do comedy they're like okay
cool do you write
and he's like that'd be like if i went
to the grocery store and i was like oh
cool you have produce do you farm yeah
sometimes it does feel that way it's
like oh you freestyle so like what are
you gonna do though you know it's like
well i don't know you know i'm gonna
freestyle and build that out and i'm
gonna see what i can build around that's
the same thing too like i did this uh
indie film yeah
and then when i came back it got a lot
of buzz and then they're like oh so when
are you gonna act again and i never saw
an act again
but you know because those influences i
went through the whole thing i tried to
be i was like i hate this [ __ ] yeah why
what was i doing for this past like year
or two you know not to say that i won't
act again but it's like the way that
people wanted me to do it there was a
specific route but it's like i've been
doing this the whole time yeah it's just
not in the way that you you see fit you
know right which was unnecessary stress
like what the [ __ ] am i putting myself
through all the stress for yeah i relate
to that so heavy bro that's exactly how
it felt like when i made my first
project the album is literally literally
called contents under pressure right
because that's how i felt i was just
like doing it under this this massive
pressure that was just being sort of
like
placed on me yeah and i really like i'm
proud of the record and it was a huge
goal of mine to get something out like
that um but i didn't really enjoy the
process of making okay yeah i was just
kind of like man this is not this is not
fun yeah you know it becomes something
else right yeah yeah yeah and uh
just like as soon as i got back to
creating content and and putting my
voice out as an improviser and
freestyler i was like yo this feels good
this feels right and same as you that's
not to say i'm not gonna release more
music right right make another album i
plan to but it's just like the process
and i have to do it my way you know what
i mean that's not home base for you
that's just like kind of a
branch off from you know yeah it's
something that that that can um you know
it's another tool and a way for me to
express myself but i think for me
freestyling is going to be the way that
i create my albums yeah and it's weird
too because sometimes people look at
what they think is missed opportunities
based on themselves they go exactly oh
you could have been a huge mainstream
artist it's like who the [ __ ]
why is this a miss opportunity for me
yeah right because you see fit it's just
the odd conversation yeah sometimes i
feel like this are you trying to make me
feel bad about my life exactly
this says trolls bro it's so crazy yeah
it's like you don't want to climb so
high up a ladder that's leaning on the
wrong wall yeah you know what i mean
like that's beautifully said yeah yeah
that's exactly what it is it's a very
odd place to be at you know and i think
like sometimes too like i said they just
project what they want to see what they
want into you exactly it's like if i was
so he was like well if you were but
you're not so excited you're not in this
position let me sit with my choices in
my life because 100 when i make these
choices i got to deal with the
consequences not you you know i'm living
this [ __ ] out
so like if you were me that'd be really
trippy
three [ __ ] words free style for the
next six minutes enjoy and then walk
away exactly so what's that said then
like do you have
one of i'm not going to say like your
ultimate goal but one of you have like a
big goal in mind that you want to
achieve at some point in your life
what you're doing right now yeah i think
like for me man i'm i'm really enjoying
what i'm doing right now and what i'm
enjoying the most about it is
that again i get to i get to be myself i
get to put my ideas out there and and
most importantly i get to um have these
positive interactions with other human
beings you know and i think that whole
thing of like interacting with other
humans and lifting people up and making
people feel good is really what i've
realized i'm the most passionate about
and freestyling and music are are my
ways of doing that so yeah for me man
like i want to do that at scale you know
like i want to travel the whole world
and be able to freestyle and perform and
rap for larger and larger audiences and
and engage in that you know energy
exchange of of me pushing my my
freestyle out there and then people
reacting to it and that energy coming
back to me and yeah creating that
feedback loop of energy so yeah i guess
i mean that's kind of like a weird
answer i don't have like a one tangible
thing like i want to have a number one
hit record or i want to
you know um
you sell a million records or anything
like that it's more it's more so just to
continue kind of on the path i'm on and
continue to grow and experience enough
said man i mean look what better
i guess scenario than to not only be
able to make a living off what you love
to do but also to see the world and
connect with people while you're doing
dude that's like 100
that's you're living the dream at that
point you know what i mean yeah and so
like for me i feel like no amount of
money or other experiences can replace
that for that feeling you get from that
you know
it's and it's only a matter of like in
terms of longevity
like how you feel about it right right
because there can come a point in time
where you feel like ah you know what i'm
not feeling the same kind of passion
that i used to have for what i'm doing
right now right maybe i want to shift
gears now and you know try something
else right yeah but till that time comes
man i think it's very visible and like
you could see when whenever you're
rapping doing your videos whatever that
you're passionate and happy with what
you do and i think that resonates with
people man i think that resonates with
people and i think that's why you were
able to build the community that you
have in such a short span of time yeah i
appreciate that man yeah no you know
what i'm i'm so passionate about it i
love what i get to do
it's crazy you know and i've always been
a musician since i was a kid like i said
you know so regardless of what i had to
do to make money
when i got home from work i would be
making music exactly what i mean like at
the end of the day like
i'm always going to be a musician you
know no matter what yeah even if i
didn't rap for the next five years
i would still identify as a musician you
know what i mean so it's important to me
to maintain that passion and maintain
that love and like when if it does get
stressful if too much of it feels like
work it's like okay let's take a step
back like let me just listen to some
dope [ __ ] as a fan you know
hey man well that wraps up this podcast
that was [ __ ] amazing you guys know
so much about you had no idea you were a
[ __ ] jazz drummer yes all the pizzas
are [ __ ] connecting in my head right
now but hey man shout out whatever you
want right now to the camera yes uh
harry mack oh yo we have a show coming
up in irvine
september 2nd let's go at the irvine
improv
make sure y'all come out it's going to
be crazy fully improvised show oh wow so
uh um all musical artists are different
types of artists too it's like just just
me man just oh just you know
okay let's go
that's dope yeah i mean this could be
opening dj saturday yeah yeah yeah he's
just gonna be with me but yeah but yeah
fully improvised show um it's gonna be
crazy it's gonna be crazy i'm super
excited about it so hope to see some of
y'all out there cool well you can check
out ed2 at ed2 everything all right and
check out secret society jesus brings
every thursday and sundays make sure you
go to a show uh hearing back everything
right harry mack everything at harry
mack youtube.com harry mack uh except
for tick tock and twitch which are harry
mac official okay well let's go we'll
see you all next time somebody take your
name yeah there's some other harry
potter
[ __ ] you harry macklin you the imposter
bro
so check it out right now in this
section you guys are gonna hear what he
does on omegle what harry mack does on
omegle not what he does in life bro
that's right that's right thanks for
maybe you look like a piece of [ __ ]
all right like that was very unnecessary
but uh so this was gonna happen i got a
computer over here when i hit a beat
and edrick is gonna give harry
three [ __ ] words
and then he's just gonna go off the top
all right my balls are tingling yeah
mine too you can just throw them at me
too as we go if you want to keep just
you can keep you know what
[ __ ] the three word limit we're just
gonna keep throwing words out swap them
out just lob them out yeah we're just
gonna love him out while he goes bro
all right
first word harry sunflower yo yo yo yo
yo do it off the top got that raw tongue
power every time i'm flowing i'll be
growing like a sunflower hmac got the
type of lyrics that you need back in the
day yo i was chewing sunflower seeds
hmac i'm off the top my flow is never
written word to sunflower seed shells
cause i'm steady spitting hmac i'm live
in the rhythm and my flow's not a drag
yo i'm about to pull this right out the
bag
tripod oh yeah when i rhyme i be fly
guard ain't no challenge i'ma keep my
balance like a tripod every time i
damage your amateur with the stamina i
stand tall like a tripod for your camera
uh you know i really press a bigger
threat my lyrics might be more cancerous
than a cigarette hmac y'all know i'm
good in person my mental excels while
they writing warnings from the surgeon
general uh and people be loving the way
that i spit and like the tip of your
cigarette max stays lit yeah ain't no
way to quit man my flow's off kilter
i'mma kill you i'm like a cigarette with
no filter yeah i'm on point y'all know
i'm really out here rapping sick i might
have missed her but i think you said
cabinet yes hey yo is that correct harry
mack i'm going flowing off of the top
just to show em yeah and y'all know that
i'd be wrecking and stuff rappers got
their mics and cabinets collecting that
dust not me cause i utilize the tools on
the daily every time i'm rhyming y'all
know i'ma drive them all crazy [ __ ] yeah
hey yo i'm making rappers panic till i'm
out of breath i got more depth in the
oceanic it's cherry mac i'm here you
know i'm never gonna fail i prevail with
lyricism that be fat is a whale i'm a
scorcher dropping facts like a reporter
i'm a killer in this industry like i was
an orca yeah every time i rhyme you know
i'm gonna bring a phrase i'ma lay low
like the ocean full of stingrays yeah
any problem i face when i'm solving are
we still on the ocean bars i'm
intelligent dolphin hmac i'm off the top
i'm telling you in anguish yeah and
we're the dolphins cause i speak a deep
language yeah i'm all up in it and i'm
spitting it ill they like mag how do you
breathe yo i got me some gills
[Music]
yo i make these rappers flee the scene
hey yo off with their heads like a
guillotine h mac man it is quite
confusing we're the guillotines i got
perfect execution
i'll never be dead cause every time i'm
rhyming i'd be chopping your head off
i'm spitting with passion and lyrically
flashing every time i rhyme that there's
the exact now addition
yo my style is so astounding when i
speak i bring you to the peak of the
mountain everything i rhyme and y'all
know that it's the cleverest i'm bout to
bring your ass right to the peak of
everest yeah check out the way that
harry matt can work here i'm breathing
even at high elevation like a sherpa
lyrics i deliver off the tip they bout
to stay true if there wasn't pika
everest then it was cave delorean
yo i be scorching them stars going to
war like mandalorian hmac i'm dropping
them bomb vocals yeah i'm in millennium
falcon like han solo h man y'all know my
lyrics more dope suffocating the track
like vader with the force choke uh hey
yo i'll be the crazy thought provoker
and it's right all my videos go viral
like baby
and the track i'm really scorching this
yeah hey yo beat the metamorphosis every
mag my problem gets solved do this for
y'all get my all and you know my flow is
fully evolved listen hey yo people see
me rapping illa this here metamorphosis
of caterpillar cause every time i do my
lyrics they be buttery and fly turn the
caterpillar to butterfly don't ask me
why i'm too high what do you say
condiment
rappers couldn't catch up no condiment
hmac my voice is prominent ill freestyle
ability i be on to it listen if you want
to step you better lay low imma spill
your blood out like some mayo hey yo
neck man you know i'm here to bust words
illest with the freestyle lyrics but yo
you must be mustard yeah oh yo i beat
you
see that moment gonna make your viewers
say that it's fake like they must have
planned the words and that there was a
slip up yeah i forgot your word give me
one more to rip up let's go
oh bro
[Applause]
oh yeah that [ __ ] was crazy oh [ __ ] that
[ __ ] was crazy bro
oh my god damn oh we gotta do one more
yeah let's do it let's do it more
can we should we use this
these are all yours
these are all royalty free no samples
okay
rolex
yeah bro i got you i had to hydrate so i
was starting with the water he was like
mac we know your freestyles are absurd
but why you still hydrating while i'm
throwing you words alright well dog i
got you you know i come through with the
flex never gave a [ __ ] about the
necklace nor the rolex yeah cause i
really got no time for the foolery and i
ain't never selling my spirit to cop
some jewelry listen they see that i'll
be flowing divine without a diamond
rolex on them still knowing that
yeah hmac when i'm rhyming i'll be very
great rap is envious of harry stayed
i'll let that marinade uh when i do it
man y'all know i came to spit it haters
this kid is greater marinate like meat
and refrigerators
y'all know i'm really bout to get props
for hip hop they marinating all inside
the ziploc yeah i ain't part of it i am
the scene delivered by the ounce bounce
like a trampoline hmac man i run it like
a aaron that's facts my lyrics fat
trampoline they'd be tearing through
that uh i'ma hit the ground yeah i be
spitting fire i'm bouncing like a
trampoline cause i'ma lift you up
metamorphosis yeah hey yo y'all know i'm
out here scorching [ __ ] dawg we all
ready to use the word
metamorphosis about to be beat negative
10 mack points for the repeat yeah hey
yo i'm about to crush the game certainly
by the way mack points is not a real
correction
[Music]
rappers are sounding whack those are the
people i be roasting doing my thing was
different from them and they've been
keeping the distance and when they
becoming the roasting through these
tracks i'm staying persistent uh y'all
know this kid is about to get higher hey
yo i'm roasting instrumentals on the
spitfire yeah hey yo i leave i feel the
bent foes when i'm finished ripping all
these instrumentals they said it's crazy
how he's switching up his tempo i think
it's obvious this music's what i'm meant
for i came to spaz i'm playing jazz my
tongue is like a drum i've been getting
it done hey yo i'm ripping it from my
soul and my spirit what's the next
channel you got i'm trying to hear it yo
i clear it out like drano when kicking
these insane flows it's really nothing
when busting erupting like volcanoes hm
hey yo y'all know that i'm great matter
of fact i cause an earthquake like
colliding plates yeah i grip up on the
mic and body bag yeah my imposters get
hit with lava i'm spitting magma
they couldn't compete with this y'all
know that i've been at home exploding
from the dome silicon yeah yo you know
my flow is fatal i ain't signing to no
label till there's money on the table
y'all know i'm spitting with flair my
vocal tone goes to beats like tables
going to chairs yeah hey yo y'all know
that i got that off the head vibe hey yo
they come up short like tables for the
bedside staircase yeah hey yo i'm
spitting in this rare place i'm slightly
climbing with rhyming like on the
staircase my level it stays on eleven
hey yo i got these rappers climbing
right up the stickers to heaven hey yo
hairy mac i'm bringing you deeper
whenever i be rhyming it's vital got
your brain twisted like a staircase that
is spiderman yeah what is that vitamin
uh i don't write again yeah every mag my
bars be exciting them memories remind me
how it felt to be 12 so i invite them in
hmac it's exciting whenever i'm flipping
it's really nothing y'all know that no
one could be a liken to me i boost your
health like vitamin c greatest rapper
really who i'm likely to be yeah all
these rappers biting me g i can't get
with that i spit facts i built this
myself i like the fighters ain't
container i'd be good for your health
yeah people love the way that hairy man
can really rock fam
hey yo i'm everybody them flames you got
me [ __ ] up you know i'm always saying
my name yeah hey yo my freestyle is real
absurd you put me on the spot and
throwing me my feeling
i'm out here straight bombing with raps
you know we bout to get a ton of hateful
comments for that yeah hey youtube
getting all this [ __ ] from the soul what
up youtube i'm talking to all of you
trolls he got greys in his head and i
really hope she dies soon yeah but you
know inside my [ __ ] is fly dude hey yo
everything i spit be sounding major i
got love for all my youtube lovers and
my youtube haters so wherever you at
from my heart that's where the raps born
i be winning on youtube or any [ __ ]
plaque comments all you gotta do is post
to your zone i'ma vomit yeah and i don't
pay no mind to the comments i mean i
listen to the true members of my
community but where i'm headed in the
future g i guess we soon to see i'm
trying to say it i gotta enjoy my
playlist otherwise i will quickly feel
the wrath that yo i killed the
instrumental and they love the way i
slay this make sure that you keeping
hairy mac up in your playlist
hey
[ __ ] that's why i say this dude
is one of the greatest if not the
greatest freestylers of all time man
thank you sir that's [ __ ] evidence
right oh my god my goodness bro and you
guys know that [ __ ] was completely
improvised off the top man yes he even
tied in the [ __ ] that we talked about in
the podcast bro i had to had to man my
[ __ ] face hurts from smiling yo let
me just let's
go let me tell you bro i haven't felt